WOULD BE.
IF CARTER PAGE, CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR TOTAL VINDICATION.
ANOTHER MAN WHO WAS ENDLESSLY
MALIGNED ON FALSE GROUNDS WAS
MICHAEL CAVUTO, ALSO AN ADVISOR
TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON, YOU'VE BEEN SHARING WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO BE YOU AND I
WONDER -- YOU HAVE BEEN
VINDICATED, YOU WEREN'T WORKING,
NEITHER ONE WAS ANYONE WORKING
FOR THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT --
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> I DO FEEL VINDICATED BUT I
SPENT TUESDAY AT THE POLICE
STATION IN MY LITTLE VILLAGE IN
WESTERN NEW YORK PRESSING
CHARGES AGAINST SOMEONE FOR
THREATENING ME ON FACEBOOK.
THIS HAS NOT ENDED YET.
I'M PRETTY SURE THAT THE REST OF
US, CARTER PAGE AND GORDON ARE
ALL SUFFERING THE SAME SLINGS
AND ARROWS I AM, WE MAY HAVE
BEEN VINDICATED BY THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION BUT I DON'T KNOW
WHEN WE ARE GOING TO GET OUR
REPUTATIONS BACK.
>> Tucker: WHAT CAN YOU DO?
YOU HAVE LOST YEARS OF YOUR
LIFE, YOUR FAMILY AS YOU TOLD US
BEFORE HAS BEEN BESIEGED.
YOU CAN'T WORK A NORMAL JOB
BECAUSE OF THIS.
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU CAN DO TO
MAKE IT RIGHT AT THIS STAGE?
>> I CAN TRY TO HELP THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IN THE SENATE TRY TO UNCOVER
WHAT REALLY HAPPENED HERE.
I WOULD LOVE TO GET BACK TO WOR
WORK.
I'M CONTACTING MY OLD CLIENTS
WHO HAD TO LEAVE ME BECAUSE OF
THIS MARK ON MY RECORD.
NOW THAT I AM VINDICATED, WHILE
I REALLY WANT TO GET BACK TO
WORK AND MAKE MONEY FOR MY
FAMILY, I WANT TO INSPIRE SOME
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL LAW SO PEOPLE
DON'T GO THROUGH THIS AGAIN.
I LOVE CARTER'S OPTIMISM -- I'M
A LITTLE BIT MORE ANGRY THAN HE
IS.
>> Tucker: I'M ANGRY WATCHING
IT, I WAS ONLY DENOUNCED AS A
RUSSIAN SPY ONCE BY A BUFFOON,
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE, I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT
YOUR LIFE HAS BEEN LIKE.
CONGRATULATIONS ANYWAY BECAUSE
WHETHER IT FEELS LIKE IT OR NOT,
OF VINDICATION.
>> I WANT TO SAY ONE THING.
PARDON GENERAL FLYNN, PARDON
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS AND PARDON
ROGER STONE RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: DON'T WAIT UNTIL
AFTER THE ELECTION, THEY DESERVE
IT NOW.